let's get into this first story with a
big shout out to elon musk
we have this clip tom elliott posted
it's nbc's mehdi hassan
saying if the neo-nazi faction of the
gop expands in november we may look back
on this as a pivotal moment when a
petulant and not so bright billionaire
casually bought one of the most
influential messaging machines and just
handed it to the far right
the first thing i have to do is point
out anybody who calls a billionaire not
so bright insane
the question is why aren't you a
billionaire it's easy yeah idiots can do
it go ahead and try the guys i would
love to see it rockets into space and
then landing them on like islands that
are a little larger than the rocket he's
also self-made
for the most part he sold paypal for to
make his first big chunk of money he
risked everything to make tesla but he
but he had white skin while doing it
yeah
his family's rich oh yeah no i'm sure
look
but hold on i i know a lot of kids whose
families were rich and instead they went
to art school and didn't get a job most
of them
all addictions if you can be an idiot
and become a billionaire just because
your parents are rich it's so easy why
aren't these people able to do it when
they call trump an idiot i'm like i mean
brash maybe but the dude turned a
million dollars into a billion dollars i
mean you gotta that's you gotta be smart
so the idea that you just have a million
dollars and become a billionaire like
that or it's not the case yeah but the
funny thing is we're talking about elon
musk and you mentioned with the rockets
he's like the first guy to land a rocket
upright
back on a platform and it's like this
tremendous feat he lowered the cost of
rocketry like 10-fold or 100-fold and
he's making space travel infinitely
cheaper
he's got star link low latency
satellites and they're like what an
idiot yeah
his political views are wrong he's an
idiot also if if having rich parents
sets you up for success and it's just a
guarantee you walk into it explain
hunter biden
oh man uh but let's be real i mean
definitely he's making money too i mean
hundred bucks making something i don't
know i spent 650 000 on a painting of
his so i don't know oh my god look i
mean craftsmanship is craftsmanship and
you have to reward good work well let's
let's talk about what uh what elon says
so elon musk responds with nbc basically
saying republicans are nazis
he then says same organization that
covered up hunter but in laptop story
had harvey weinstein's story early and
killed it and built matt lauer his rape
office lovely people
that's a low blow elon in the rape
office
when i saw that i was like i am
retweeting this this is amazing yo elon
is unleashed
you know what this is what i've been
i've been wanting to see right
i i've always asked myself this
when i was when i was younger i'm like
there's so much going on in the world
that people complain about where are
these billionaires to just do anything i
mean seriously anything like what did
oprah do she people got mad at oprah
because she she had this big event on
michigan avenue in chicago
where there's like a helicopter shot of
all these people in an audience watching
a musical performance but then all of a
sudden all the people start doing a
choreographed dance and you realize
they're all paid actors and people got
mad because they were like if you were
going to do a show do a show but this is
all one big setup i remember seeing that
and thinking like that's what they do
with their money they just get a bunch
of dancers to dance in the street where
the billboard saying like screw this guy
and f this or like i'm mad about that
like very rarely so now you get elon
musk
matt lauer's rape office
yo but check this out
pope of muscanity says it says it all
that we heard more about will smith
slapping chris rock than we heard about
gillane maxwell's trial it is also
interesting that the account tracking
the maxwell trials got natural trial got
banned when it gained traction lovely
people indeed and then elon musk says
where is their client list shouldn't at
least one of them go down and then hey
why are they already writing my suicide
story
dude
that last one strikes a little bit too
uh real because there's no way they're
gonna like the powerful elites massive
corporations politicians what are they
gonna do sit back and let a rogue
billionaire just go off i think he
answered your question why we don't see
more billionaires calling people out
because you basically paint a bullseye
on your forehead if you do that the
world is a dark dangerous place and if
you cross the wrong people man that's it
i was gonna say that i mean if you were
a billionaire who was just okay with it
all ending this would be the coolest
possible way
after grimes left him he was just like i
don't care anymore is that just going
off
oh elon elon it gets better all right
hang in there buddy hang in there guys
no
it's that movie where the politician
hires an assassin
right yeah you know what it is he hires
a guy to kill himself
so then he's just like drinking and
doesn't care anymore that's telling the
truth and everyone loves it and then he
doesn't want to die and he's like
freaking out that movie was pretty good
i liked it yeah i'm starting to think
that this is the reason that elon musk
bought twitter so that he could just um
ish post all day long this is amazing
he's going crazy didn't he do that
before kind of it's weird that they make
him out they say he's like a republican
like he doesn't seem overly political to
be honest he's he's outright called
himself a socialist yeah like he doesn't
come off his posts are a lot of like you
know jokes and but he doesn't seem super
political yeah before the show i was
thinking dude creates rocket ships to
space and mars people on earth
complaining about what what his politics
are like it's so insane that that's the
focus when you can focus on the stuff
he's building look at look at that nina
jankowicz lady the disinformation board
she pushes overt disinformation and has
so
she's supposedly like working she's
working for the democrats
when you look at elon musk i think it's
never been clearer that left and right
don't mean anything about politics it
means everything about whether you are
on your knees for the establishment or
challenging the establishment yeah also
ian you made an interesting point i
would even take it a step further
because it's not even like he has this
political agenda he's trying to force on
to people like he he's in a lot of ways
he's virtually apolitically saying let's
just make neutral spaces that's not
really a partisan stance he's not greedy
either he gave his tesla patents away
the free the yes all your patents are
belong to us move that he did i gotta
push back on james sheamus he is handing
over one of the most influential
messaging platforms to neo-nazis well
here's what i think elon's gonna do if
they don't let him buy twitter if
something falls through he's going to
build a rocket ship that projects it's
going to be like a space platform that
projects whatever he writes into the sky
like ali have you seen the drones the
fireworks drone they're replacing
fireworks with drones
kind of like uh that you can write stuff
on you know do that over every city dude
they're getting really crazy
three-dimensional like they look like
holograms in the sky that's your drone
light show way cooler than fireworks
yeah yeah they're way cooler than
fireworks and also you don't like blow
your hand off this is like two years ago
that was the cool part of the fire they
had one yeah i know well they had the
one at bitcoin miami they did uh whoa
but in china they're like oh yeah
because they can move really far really
fast and draw lines in the sky has
anyone thought about the horror of just
like someone like elon getting a
thousand drones and then being able to
command them with gloves and like
walking through new york and just like
protoss man that's how the protoss move
their battle cruisers around are there
over someone's head like a rain cloud no
no he's like he's wearing a trench coat
and he's standing on several drones he's
floating for the city you know
when anyone challenges him he just
points and a drone flies and slams into
him now we're talking bezos level like
bezos has the proprieties those ideas
actually yeah elon at least is freeing
the software code of his stuff so if i
was bezos i would legit be doing that i
would make one of those hobgoblin
gliders from spider-man and then i would
just have drones and i'd be like
is he going to set up his base in the
amazon would you if you're jeff bezos
why is
i can't remember exactly how i put it
what is it that jeremy boring said he's
like he's the most interesting guy in a
boring way like he's the most boring
interesting guy about bezos yeah what
did he say like he makes a rocket ship
and it's not cool not exciting at all
it's not like cool like elon musk
that is funny though jeff but he's he
said what did he yeah he he put it
really funny
butchered it we ruined your joke jeremy
sorry
so check this out so people responded
well when elon musk said where's their
client list someone said let's start
with you
and they show this photo where
elaine maxwell is behind elon and he
says that's a vendi fair party and she
photo bombed me in the background but
you know that already don't you who
and then someone responded skype renee
elon doesn't know guelin maxwell at all
she photobombed him once at a vanity
fair party in 2014. real question is why
vanity fair invited her in the first
place and he said that is exactly the
question indeed
dude i think
i'm you gotta look
if elon musk is gonna come out and say
where's the client list
i'm like elon buy away do what you want
to do because it's one of the most
important questions yeah that's not not
going to be answered there's no ser
any serious journalist
at the washington post at the new york
times i'll say this right now to all of
you i know that there are people at the
new york times have been working there
for two decades and you are upset about
what's happening at your newspaper i
know that there are people at the
washington post who have been there for
decades who are upset about what is
happening to your newspaper why don't
you
start demanding answers as to the client
list for maxwell and epstein
why why why isn't there any interest
from the gray lady the paper of record
and all of these big publications to
demand if this woman is being convicted
on this
she sold something to somebody
it's elon musk yeah and he's the bad guy
they're saying he's the bad guy i think
those people have families
yeah
i look at maria farmer who was one of
the former victims of the the i don't
know we call it child trafficking
racketeering thing they're doing and she
drew a painting called the set heels
s-e-t-i-l-e-s
her name is maria farmer you search
those three words together you'll get
this painting and it looks like she just
painted all the guys all the people that
were there as part of it she doesn't
have names but i mean i can't imagine
anyone digging too deep into it but this
is the deepest i've seen and it's like
it's a really disturbing image uh it's
got guillain in the middle with a bubble
around her like she's she's invincible
it's got jeffrey epstein's off up in the
corner like he's some space get it he
was the fall guy for the whole thing he
wasn't like and then of course you got i
don't even like saying these names out
loud man but you got les wexner right in
the middle there under elaine maxwell
the victoria's secret guy and uh i think
he was a big part of it but there's just
no i don't have the evidence it's just
this image thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 p.m and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you